okay we have some breaking news right
now American Apparel has terminated Dov
Charney I want to head out to Julie
Hyman at the breaking news desk you know
Julie this is a guy who was under a ton
of fire from the board they did not want
him there they ousted him as CEO and
really cited some alleged misconduct
right going back years and really cited
him as being a problem for the company
we're now learning that they are
terminating him they had been conducting
of course an investigation into his
behavior and they're still not giving a
lot of information as to the exact
details of that behavior but remember
this all started back in July as you say
he was ousted from the company was kept
on as a sort of special adviser it
seemed like there was an in-between sort
of limbo role for him as the company
figured out legally what it was going to
do next so they did this internal
investigation as you say now the
company's thing based on this
investigation the special committee
determined that it would not be
appropriate for mr. Charney to be
reinstated as CEO or as an officer or
employee of the company and its doesn't
give any more details than that in terms
of what exactly that investigation found
now the other big piece of news coming
out is not just the dub tourney is going
but at American Apparel has named a
permanent CEO and that is polish
Schneider who is a veteran of the real
the retail and apparel industry she's
worked at Warnock o bcbgmaxazria a
laundry by shelli segal so a number of
different brands that she's been
involved with frankly I don't know that
much more about her except for the
resume that's here but as you know Trish
American Apparel had been struggling and
so we'll see here if she's able to come
in here and turn it around without the
assistance of Charney who who built the
company as she joked recently now he's
free to go head up Abercrombie I guess
uh you know but you know what I always
found it and do find remarkable about
him I mean he was a guy who was very
committed to the business he may have
had some personal flaws and some of that
information may come out in this
investigation that they did but he was a
guy who really just ate slept breathed
american apparel you know starting at
this effectively a t-shirt company and
growing it into what it it has become
you know and I think Julie what's so
interesting is it is kind of a familiar
story with some really successful
initially successful entrepreneurs
they're just sort of tunnel visioned
that was him and they may be very
committed but they may also have these
sort of personal flaws and again we'll
learn more as as the results of that
investigation come forward but he was
very challenged in terms of his public
image for this company when you look at
you know Google for example and they got
some adult management in there you look
at Facebook for example terrific
entrepreneur and Mark Zuckerberg but he
was able to dwell okay don't management
I don't know we want to compare Mike
Mark Zuckerberg and dub Charlie I mean
no we don't know them so saying that you
know entrepreneurs often are just these
incredibly creative people but at some
point and Paul Sweeney's joining me here
along with Alex barranca on set at some
point you've got to make that leap from
being this terrific entrepreneur to
being a mature CEO and that may have
been one of the flaws that he had we saw
that also with chip Wilson right at
Lululemon who kind of would say whatever
he thought we know he said right here on
this set that it was women's fault that
those yoga pants were see-through rather
than the company's um but you know there
needs to be sort of this filter and this
adult approach to running a company and
that's exactly right the optics of how
what a CEO is saying these days with
social media with consumers actually
invested in kind of what is the brand of
the company what is the personal message
of the company if you have somebody kind
of shooting from the hip saying things
doing things interacting with employees
in an unsavory fashion consumers really
see that up front and center these
and they will take their dollars
elsewhere and find Dino products at a
company that they truly believe in you
know is his alleged behavior almost
seemed to have been less of an issue for
American Apparel's board however all
point out during the days when the
company was doing well it was
interesting that once retail started to
go through all the challenges it went
through suddenly the board awakened to
okay is this guy a liability here and
obviously they concluded that in fact he
was yeah i think you know rising sales
on a you know rising your steady stock
price will you know salve a lot of
wounds here but i think once things turn
turn sideways it gives the boards i
think a little bit of cover if nothing
else to take a look at some other
behavior and some other issues you know
he was able to get funding to come in
and purchase a bigger stake when i spoke
to some members of the board initially
and and I raised this issue with them
how is it that you were able to keep
this guy on as long as you did despite
all of these allegations why was it not
an issue back then but suddenly as an
issue when sales are looking weak and
they made the point that he was such a
strong force in the company he owned
such a large portion of the company more
than fifty percent that it made it
extraordinarily difficult for them to
separate and now we're at a time where
teen retailers are especially challenged
you've seen it with abercrombie with
american eagle with air pistol so in
this you know company also goes for that
same subset so again as these problems
come in you need a strong leader who can
kind of take it by the horns and guide
it out in a way that investors and
consumers are gonna applaud and not kind
of shy away from you know it was
challenging i think cuz on the one hand
on the board and certainly consumers
liked what he represented that sort of
you know recklessness you know I
remember Alan Meyer who was a board
member telling Bloomberg Businessweek
and I'm going to share this with you
quote if you took out the sex it would
be kind of boring if you took out the
idealist component sweatshop free it
would just be kind of sleazy but you put
the two of them together and you have
something that's interesting it's edgy
but it's also strangely wholesome at the
same time and this is what Dov Charney
was sort of trying to bring to the
business so the question
now is how does it do without him you
gotta keep capturing attention you know
that was the old narrative for them so
what are they going to do what's the new
bright shiny object for them to bring in
these customers section owe me some for
how long and how do you deal with it
this in an environment when retail is
continuing to struggle as much as it has
but again the news being that a doctor
knee is no longer at at American Apparel
he's been terminated for cause